hey there and welcome to this proflos
quick tip i
am cameron and today i'm going to show
you how to do
a wireframe 3d render inside of after
effects
if you don't know after effects cc comes
with cinema 4d light
so what we have to do is we have to go
and we have to create a new
maxon cinema 4d file which is right here
okay so we click that
it's going to ask us to save out our
file so let's call this
wireframe and it's going to save a
cinema 4d file
and then what it's going to do is it's
going to launch cinema 4d lite
and it's going to launch it here in the
foreground and we're going to work in
cinema 4d
okay so here we are inside of cinema 4d
and what we're going to do now is we are
going
to create a new object it can be any
type of object i'm going to use a
pyramid
click that and what's important to note
here is that you have to
select the object over here in your
window and hit c and that's going to
make the object editable it's very
important you do this
for this process to work inside of
cinema 4d lite
now inside of normal versions of cinema
4d it's much easier to do wireframe
renders but this is the hack for cinema
4d lite
so here we are i'm going to go ahead and
i'm just going to set a keyframe
for the rotation of this
pyramid i'm going to go to the end of
the timeline here and i'm just going to
make the
pyramid rotate 360 degrees
around type that in really quick
and we're going to set another keyframe
boom there we go and we've got
a moving pyramid here very simple
rotation so how do we make it wireframe
so we're going to double click here
under textures
we've got our texture we're going to
drag it onto our object here
double click our texture we're going to
open up the window here we go
this is the magic we're going to turn
off the color turn off reflex
reflectance we're going to turn on
luminance and we're going to turn on
alpha okay under alpha texture
effects proximal
shader there we go we're going to double
click that come into it we're going to
turn on
vertices edges in distance
two and we're going to drag our pyramid
right into the objects here
and we're just going to hit a quick
render here and you're going to see it's
a wireframe
great file save jump back
into after effects inside of after
effects render settings
standard final there
is our pyramid and if we preview this
at full res you can see here it's going
to rotate
it's an awesome looking wireframe render
if you wanted this to be something other
than white
under the luminous channel back in
cinema you could change it to
any color you want besides white but
there we go if you enjoyed this quick
tip
pro flow quick tip i would invite you to
check out proflos plus
over at motionscience.tv it is chock
full of
techniques trends workflows things
ways to create really awesome work
inside of after effects
that's all i got for you today